la cathédrale de
Saint-Denis
au cours de la première moitié du 19e
siècle Saint-Denis se dote de très
nombreuses églises entrepris en 1829 le
premier grand chantier est celui de
l'église de Saint-Denis devenu
cathédrale en
1851 son plan basilical est dessiné par
l'ingénieur Jean Baptiste du l'église
possède de niveaux de style néoclassique
sa façade présente un Porsche à TR
arcades surmonté d'un fronton
elle accueille les premiers fidèles en
1832 20 ans plus tard la place est
aménagée et décorée d'une fontaine
monumentale de 1856 à 1863 la cathédrale
fait l'objet de travaux d'embellissement
le portique qui n'avait pu être
construit faute de moyens est enfin
réalisé son fronton est décoré de
sculpture représentant le martyre de
Saint-Denis aujourd'hui surmonté d'un
splendide plafond à caisson la ne est
rythmée au rez-dechaussée par des
piliers supportant des arcades
la chair monumentale en TEC a été
réalisée par des ouvriers indiens qui
ont également sculpté les Stales du cœur
et les
lambries les peintures de laab baie
moiro évoquant la vie de Saint-Denis et
l'histoire religieuse de la France date
de 1905 année de la séparation des
Églises et de
l'État protéger au titre des Monuments
Historiques depuis
1975 la cathédrale est l'un des premiers
édifices néoclassiques de la
Réunion elle a retrouvé sa splendeur du
19e siècle depuis les restaurations des
années